something I want to tell you narration
you want to know the very first thing
that entered my mind
coins oh no you're about to make some
sort of weird coin analogy aren't you
I'm a coin in the United States Army I
was meant to in the Year 1980 right
before everything went black you want to
know the very last thing that entered my
mind
not remotely who puts their purse on the
edge of the pier women who want to be
impressed by Channing Tatum do and they
need because he jumps into the ocean to
rescue the purse of the girl he does not
know this guy is a class a stalker
already but thanks to the power of
Nicholas Sparks he's Romeo movie
literally focuses on the depths men will
go to get vagina good thing she decided
to run all the way down here or else the
battle for who take Savannah her purse
would have gotten awkward the director
said let's mix it up this time and give
the hero love interest in Apple but not
show him taking a bite
it'll be like his symbolic decision not
to be an asshole I'm not his type
you mean all it takes is for me to
recognize that you I'm my type and I get
to have the hot girl damn I should have
watched this movie sooner it's odd that
it took this long and this movie for
henry thomas to reunite with ET dog or
cat does something he or she only does
with other people to a stranger and
prove suitability cliche no enough since
he was born and none of the next several
hours of conversation were important in
this budding relationship as we take you
now directly to the bonfire
oh I gotta get out of here before I wolf
out also good thing it's a full moon
because a waxing crescent moon doesn't
get anyone later hey random ass guy he
met earlier in the day shows up to get
John a ride in the middle of the night
for the record if you do anything to
hurt Savannah god damn it does he have
to be one of those guys plus damn didn't
John just meet her today these guys park
like assholes I mean even if you're not
parking in a main pedestrian
thoroughfare which I think you are you
also parked perpendicular to the only
other car parked here what are you doing
just when John thought he had made the
perfect seduction random asshole who
knows about him shows up your dad
tonight whoa whoa this is the first date
and he hasn't even kissed you yet you're
going to know more about his dad than
you do about John by the time this night
is over
and honestly who gives a shit about
these characters so far John Doe for a
purse she hates Jason Street I guess
match made in heaven
that he had the free silver policy
is it a bad sign that I've learned more
about coins that I have about any of the
characters so far now we figure out that
nothing John did was really all that
impressive because she finds everything
impressive except the asshole guy who
knocked a person to the ocean what hmm
someone say something about fun movie
blew crushes me into loving it I curse
that's supposed to be a fault no woman
that is a strength too bad the movies
pg-13 though and you can't show too much
of that fault you're on spring break
though right the PIA talking about
spring break is at a maximum one week it
was literally the most beautiful day
ever created but then Nicholas Sparks
overruled God and made it rain so they
would have a reason to kiss John and
Savannah christened somebody's new
hurricane replacement house before it's
built take that karma dude you've got
the girl so you can stop being amazing
already love montage is still going it's
the summer of 2001 so there's definitely
nothing on the horizon that will put a
stop to all this happiness boyfriend
[Music]
incapable promises did you say my dad's
like Alan Sam my dad's retarded or
something yeah that's racist also how in
the world is John not discussed his dad
in his condition in these past two weeks
she demanded to see him on their first
night of dating and this never came up
it's like this guy was planted here just
in case John got into an argument with
Savannah and he's just drunk enough to
be more of an asshole than usual Tim
thinks it's a good idea to basically
sneak up on a guy who was beating tons
of ass like he's in a GI Joe flick right
now also now I get it
Tim's the guy and Savannah's going to
find acceptable once John leaves but
only after 9/11 I don't know what I was
thinking sneaking up behind an angry
Green Beret like that probably wasn't so
much you that made the decision but the
screenwriter that happens sometimes I
hear do you John roll credits
write it all down John scribble it in a
notebook roll quick Oh for a movie I was
just watching this man oh my god this
entire movie is going to be letters
isn't it nine minutes of letter reading
only one movie in 2010 dares to show you
what it's like to make coins and sort
mail asshole from earlier in the film is
conveniently at the same College and in
the same class as Savannah I had this
idea this dream I want to open up a
summer camp for autistic kids I don't
want to cure cancer cause a rainbow with
my tears and baked gluten-free pumpkin
cookies for every single kid in the
world a place where they can ride horses
as much as they want also she wants to
pay our autistic kids and horses animals
maybe but the things that paralyzed
Christopher Reeve
you create an art camp for autistic kids
or a small animal petting zoo maybe
these ones in their life please they
won't have to worry about a thing except
traumatic head injury from startle horse
kicking but it's a full moon here
tonight which makes me think of you
because I know that no matter what I'm
doing no matter where I am
this moon will always be the same size
as yours well John is a discount fievel
mousekewitz
someone saw on americantale entire movie
is narrated letters i guess they took
the coin into a pawn shop even though
every single thing visible in this shot
suggests it's actually a music shop
whatever my point is why are you having
some random pawnshop guy appraise your
reer coin oh that's good I love warm
milk you spent all of our money on coins
get a friggin fridge that works asshole
kid is asshole sure but he's kind of
pretty goddamn good point if you ask me
[Music]
everyone in this South Carolina college
has someone they know directly affected
by the 9/11 attacks
post 9/11 in Savannah is somehow allowed
to do this in Airport and not get taste
that's great but I'm wondering what some
random dude messing with his belt is
thinking about all this right now
sweet also a movie decides to put a mini
notebook scene in a movie that is
basically a modern notebook written by
the same guy the inconvenience of post
9-11 air travel is apparently tolerable
when you see young people in love I feel
like mr. Tyree story is a way better
story than this romance between Savannah
and John but people don't pay tickets to
see mr. tyrese story they go to see to
pretty people falling in love for the 16
quadrillion of time and that's a damn
shame
holy Sh Amanda ciphered looks amazing in
that dress anyway damn shame how did a
dude this socially anxious ever managed
to seduce a woman and conceive a child
the stood who has been deployed in a
combat zone is somehow not understanding
of his father's obvious mental health
issues selfish much I admit this guy was
an asshole before but he's clearly
trying to make amends so John is a dick
for leaving him hanging like hey you
know we'll be jealousy but I think that
Tim here either hard to beat you to the
punch
Oh surprise Henry Thomas just showed up
out of nowhere at this party you got to
stop sneaking up on people Henry Thomas
so you boys can come home safe and sound
I won't be over anytime soon what a dick
what do you mean by we John has 18 hours
here on American soil and waited most of
them to tell Savannah he was realistic
just all that matters okay here all that
matters to me that in my duty to my
fellow soldiers which overrides you
actually but just those two things which
are really just one thing oh come on
that's way too much pressure I mean how
do we time something like that oh wait
what are you talking about wait maybe
she didn't mean what I thought you meant
of course it could have just been an
invitation to bang in the barn
either way come with me has way too many
connotations without proper context and
a Kama Sutra manual pg-13 sex
I mean who gives a shit right Channing
Tatum's left arm you live on a horse
farm and your greatest pipe dream is to
run a horse camp for autistic kids why
are you doing that already
your dad clearly has money to burn
nothing's changed that's not an answer
but if you read between lines it means
I'm gonna start fucking that dude you're
the least worried about this is probably
gonna be seen as some kind of terrible
thing but movie presents the issue is
that John has no choice but to reenlist
down for the 9/11 terrorist attack
real-life John could just as easily have
chosen to stay in Mary Savannah and his
patriotism would not in any way be in
doubt
Savannah writes back to John during
important class she probably desperately
needs in order to start the horse
factory of sadness mail sniffing I don't
mean to be a dick but they knew each
other and dated all of what two weeks
this is some serious dedication for that
short of dating period I mean damn
I wish I had that cliche
yeah enough for today events are then
mysteriously Savannah stop writing
though we only learned about that
through montage because this movie is
75% montage of course job Savannah gives
the guy named John a literal Dear John
letter smacking us in the head with its
deer jaundice my life without you guys
movie basically says shut up bitch we
get the gist of the letter you're an
extremely selfish person for being
unable to wait two years for a guy
you've only really known two weeks
Oh burning the girlfriend letters I
actually did this once in college don't
lie
honestly it felt good help me purge but
it's still cliche as hell somebody else
we gotta hide the order for the purposes
of this movie and apparently for John
himself
she's keeping who it is a surprise she
stopped writing you and when she finally
does send a letter it's not only a
breakup letter but it's also when I got
engaged to some dude letter Wow full-on
bitch that girl went Jesus okay time to
start thinking about your time at the US
Mint so far I love your coin analogy
like I could see someone sticking you in
a vending machine to buy soda at this
point also oh no John got hurt while
deployed I'd be shunkan surprised if I
had never seen a movie before you're in
a hospital in Germany other than the
fact that your girl is marrying someone
else of course I'll be extending
extending Terry has been three months
Jesus it's been three months since he
got shot he still can't get over
Savannah surely there are plenty of
other babes who will lose their purses
in the ocean you can fall in love with
but we're sending her home to the States
John I'm sorry we've just got the news
oh no his dad's dead right oh well I
mean that's not good obviously but the
way that dude was talking what an
asshole thing to say if I'd have been
there to find him like that earlier do
you think it would have made a
difference I doubt it I really do but if
you had been there it probably wouldn't
have happened in the first place so you
can see the catch-22 in life ma'am you
okay how you feeling I collected too
many coins coins Oh
so the letter was to his dad all along
that's touching and this is actually a
pretty great scene but does this movie
really about the relationship between
him and his dad I feel like at least one
or two scenes are missing for this to
pay off like the movie wants it to
hospital staff leave these two alone for
bonding time though I'm still wondering
why he's left alone in the hallway this
long it's too late at a sir face things
you owe my father's death that I'm sure
you've heard about how
Wow Savannah puts another dagger into
John by prominently showing her wedding
ring when reacting to the news
Savannah thinks the home alone face is
the face you make when you find out your
former boyfriend's dad died also how is
no one told her of John's dad's death in
this small town over surprise Henry
Thomas this guy's preparation for the
role must have been sneaking up on
people even in photos honestly I don't
know why this even had to be a surprise
John was got to find out sooner or later
initially after he was diagnosed he was
so often listed holy crap he has cancer
it's almost like the movie wants us to
feel better about him moving in on
Savannah by giving him a condition that
makes you an asshole for being mad at it
the guy was already nice enough as it
was so this is overdoing it I wish that
weren't the case but she's never looked
at me the way she used to look at you
well good thing she was able to pity
marry you and you're going to be out of
the way soon like it never happened she
gets the husband she wants the kid she
wants to take care of it's a happy
ending for everyone except Tim because I
used to have sex with you and then you
got impatient and left me for the
e-ticket
called me I agree the Dear John breakup
letter was rude but how does she call
you when you repeatedly talked about how
you couldn't even tell her where your
work anyone but me wondering if these
two would had an easier time making it
work if they could dance together in a
sexy way that won the big talent show
and paralleled their love we love each
other but we can't be together face
did you ever seen that movie The
Notebook well it's weird that's not a
couple years ago and I thought damn this
is exactly like my life whenever your
romantic comedy is dragging a mere 12
minutes from the end of the end credits
throw some awkward accident into the mix
to spice things up if I wasn't so
attracted to people with special needs
man if only John could have a broken arm
or something I could work with that I
could justify ending my marriage for
that John gets mad and hits the steering
wheel three times and nothing else but
somehow sets off the windshield wipers
look he then has to conspicuously use
his other hand to turn off for the left
side lever that clearly wasn't touched
when the bullsh wiper started wiping
I can understand him placing great value
on the original coin he and his dad
found but using it to determine military
operations
that's exactly why people hate America
dude it's argument okay this story
important letter is conveniently somehow
delivered while on active assignment Tim
received an anonymous donation oh good
John used his father's coin collection
money to buy Tim a couple more months oh
nice
it's basically delaying the inevitable
which is what this movie is doing right
now whether it's those first two weeks I
got to spend with you I just realized
all this bull based on the two-week
summer playing chases of all the Bulls
in all the movies these two fuckers meet
by chance in some huge city be
Nicholas Sparks no one died I mean
except the dad and the sick temporary
husband of course I thought for sure
John was gonna die at the end
[Music]
you just use made your own fire okay
look you got out I do okay
care to enlighten me where'd you get
your scar my father was a drinker and a
fiend
[Music]
you
you know the people in this movie could
only have endured through copious
amounts of wine I've been thinking about
it no one in this movie gets to be happy
for more than a few minutes everyone's
being miserable John gets two tours of
duty gets fucking shot his dad's an
asshole his girl dumps him by letter
after getting engaged to another dude I
mean how did he get through back
John's dad's an asshole but it's not his
fault he's plagued by anxiety another
group for his whole damn life collects a
few stupid coins and then dies nice guy
dude has an autistic son he's raising
alone plays second fiddle marries a girl
who doesn't love him gets cancer is
cancer suffering gets extended by John
for a couple of months and then he dies
Savannah has a long-distance
relationship gets bored shacks up with a
nice guy just because she likes helping
autistic kids gets widowed and
off-screen was kicked by horses multiple
times how do you get through that it's
not just movies though I found this
works in the real world as well
hey Jeremy you have to send three fast
and furious movies in a row how do you
get through that kind of thing
hey Jeremy millions of people don't get
sarcasm and many of them think you're a
dick hey Jeremy Disney just announced
another live-action remake of a beloved
animated classic look I'm not saying
wine is the answer to all of life's
problems but it can help you forget them
and in moderation anyway the good people
at Club W have some fantastic lines I've
tried them and they're interested in
sending some of it straight to your door
and if you go to club w.com slash
cinemasins they have a special offer
just for you fine people and your first
bottle is free free2play
it'd have to be something bold and spicy
and assholey
so if you like wine and you're old
enough to drink and I cannot stress
enough how illegal it is to drink when
you're not old enough or to help
facilitate said underage drinking head
on over to club.com slash cinemasins
right this minute and get on board the
Wine Train
[Music]